new in theaters this weekend Joker what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
[Music]
is it just me or is it getting crazier
out there at last Joker hits theaters
this weekend in this standalone origin
story joaquin phoenix plays arthur fleck
a man who is beaten down mocked and is
never taken seriously as society
continues to wear on him he starts to
crack and see the whole world as being
one big joke and it isn't long before he
completely breaks and he himself becomes
a joker the film is to be a version of
the Joker we haven't seen on the big
screen and we'll launch DC black a whole
different universe of comic-book
inspired films with a much darker and
serious tone this movies for you if
you're down for a grim and gritty origin
story you want to see the film that got
an eight-minute standing ovation at the
Venice Film Festival or you're gonna be
that guy and dress as Joker for
Halloween going as Harley Quinn so that
is your weekend ticket will you see and
check back next week to see who's a
better actor Will Smith or Will Smith
who's the second cut
[Music]